what is it that
inspired you to rap the way you rap
originally
because you um you know i always have
this talk with uh with with the homie
ritz
um that when it comes to like tech nine
two we've talked about you a lot
when it comes to chopping there's nobody
who can
uh really
like you like when you rap it's so clean
some people can rap fast but
it's really hard to understand like you
enunciate so perfectly every single like
it's it's to me that's what it's about
that that's
that's the limit of it is is how clear
can you say your words at a certain
pace okay you know so to me that's what
it's about
it's a complete package and once once
one is
over the other one then you you're not
really doing it the right way but when
did you start to master that like what
and what were the influences that kind
of made you decide to start rapping that
way
this was early on just really because i
was doing so many um
so many rhymes where i'm having punch
lines and stuff like that and
like more into battles like the younger
stage
you know and i wanted to sound different
make something different
right or just a new flow
right so i started like changing up the
flow and making different patterns and
then
every once in a while you were uh you
know uh coming up the street and not be
broken into the beat
yeah and then just a little more than a
little more and then you start to hear
a few other rappers doing it here and
there you know oh man
and then one day i just decided i want
to make a whole song like that i'm like
i always make little phrases like that
let me make a whole song like that
you know then i started making songs
like mr tongue twisters
that's crazy so what year what year was
mr tongue twister
man a long time ago 91 or something like
that 91 yeah
that's so crazy you know it's crazy too
cause i think it was 91
i was i was four